The chain or crochet cast-on is a very
useful technique for machine knitters.
It doesn't have as much stretch as some
methods, but it is good when you want
to match your cast-on to your bind-off
for scarves and blankets, for example.
Start by forming a slip
knot over your latch tool.
Place the tool between the first two
needles on the left side of the bed.
Position the yarn from the mast
on the left of the first needle.
Reach up and catch the yarn
in the hook of the tool.
Pull down and pull the newly formed loop
through the loop on the tool.
Holding the new loop in place,
put the tool between
the second and third needle.
And repeat this procedure
across all of the needles.
When you reach the end of the needles
in work, secure the last
loop on the last needle.
You'll notice that by just chaining on the
needles, it's difficult to hang weights.
A cast-on comb would solve this problem,
but a cast-on comb isn't always available.
Try starting with waste
yarn and ravel cord first.
Or try using a cast on rag.
I'm using a swatch from a previous
project and hanging it on the needles.
There's no need to be neat and tidy,
you'll be removing this later.
After the rag is on the needles, knit one
row of ravel cord and hang the weights.
I've pulled all the needles
out to make the cast on easier.
You'll now chain cast-on
over all the needles.
When you remove the work from the machine,
you can easily pull out the ravel
cord and remove the cast-on rag.
This technique can be done any machine,
and you'll have a beautiful chain edge.